[Musique]
aussi sujet
la guitare les maths et les barbecues
[Musique]
mariana et carlos sont venus s'établir
au québec il y a vingt ans en apportant
leurs traditions dans leurs bagages
le yerba maté ochir pamatai comme le
prononce les argentins est une infusion
qui fait partie de leur quotidien
le mans 17 une infusion
c'est une oeuvre qui viennent d'une
région de l'argentine plutôt disons que
ça patine aussi le look et les paras nu
et c'est une aire veut et qui on met
dans un récipient qui on a pu mater
lèvres sellette chervaz notre gestion
cherche à mater le récipient ses ailes
mater et non les mains dedans on met de
l'eau et on les voit avec une paille
m'en souviens pas quand est-ce que j'ai
commencé à boire du matin c'est comme
manger je ne sais pas parce que nos
parents c'est la première chose qu'ils
nous demandent c'est d'apprendre est à
l'honneur du matin leurs filles ont pu
découvrir ce rituel en visitant la
famille en argentine
c'est vraiment très omniprésente dans la
vie de tout le monde
si on veut à la maison de la famille et
des amis peu importe les maths il lit
sur la table il dans la cuisine y est
dans la chambre à la plage au parc les
gens isri nice puis il boit l'ensemble
j'ai toujours dit quelqu'un qui était
passionnée par les langues plus
particulièrement par l'espagnol nicolas
bour pris un jeune entrepreneur qui a
développé le marché du mat et au canada
s'est passionné pour cette infusion lors
de séjours en amérique du sud
dès mon arrivée là bas j'ai des jeux
j'ai remarqué que les gens aiment v
cette boisson locke key vraiment
différente de tout ce que j'avais vu
auparavant
puis le mari ma porte est vraiment un
effet totalement différent qui me donne
un peu l'effet de stimulation du café
par contre tout en restant vraiment
détendue et à la caféine que vous nous
apportez c'est l'effet stimulant con
qu'on recherche un peu là pour ça pour
se réveiller les se donner de l'énergie
par contre la théobromine devenir
balancer cet effet l'homme
dans les pays producteurs il existe
différentes façons de traiter le produit
en argentine et en uruguay du système de
vieillissement en fait qui est ajusté
comme le vin par exemple la plante doit
être stationnés condyle et les stations
la mienne tôt pendant deux ans il va
être rangé dans les gros sac de 50 kg
puis la yerba va être vieillie
on peut infuser le yerba maté à la
manière de thé en sachets ou en théière
par exemple mais la façon traditionnelle
et de l'ain fusé dans le match et la
première étape d'ajouter lier bottes
dans ma gorge
donc je vais remplir jusqu'à la moitié
ou jusqu'au trou encore ensuite on
secoue légèrement la gourde pour que
l'herbe se retrouve sur le côté
de cette façon on verse un peu d'eau
dans la partie dégagée bouillant et si
l'herbe par le dessous avec une eau à 70
degrés celsius
ne reste plus qu'à insérer la bombilla
cette paille qui sert aussi de filtres
en longeant la paroi intérieure jusqu'au
fond ajoutez de l'eau et déguster
immédiatement merci doucement doucement
je veux pas que
oui c'est très amer mais c'est une mais
c'est bon c'est très parfumée ses traits
et herbacées je dirais que ça goûte
davantage une une tisane amer quinté sur
nous dès la fin du modèle matt reeves a
été refusée jusqu'à 15 fois durant
durant la même avant midi la même
journée donc c'est vraiment différent
d'un thé ou d'un café qu'on va refuser
on va super sentai puisse se terminer on
la boit
cet engouement pour le yerba maté a
ouvert un nouveau marché pour des
boissons ou mat est prête à boire
c'est un peu une porte d'entrée dans le
monde du mat est définitivement consommé
du matin dans la gold c'est pau s'est
pas fait pour tout le monde
la coutume veut qu'on se partage le maté
il ya une personne qui est la personne
assignée
ça veut dire que alors lui il va voir sa
bouilloire ou son terme entre et lui il
va voir les récipients et ça va faire le
tour de rôle chacun va voir à son tour
le matin mais c'est les mêmes mater avec
la même faille mais l'aco vide ami un
frère cette habitude c'est comme grand
recommandation de la part du
gouvernement ne sais pas ce qu'ils le
savent de ne pas les faire et pas
partager la paille alors à chacun sa
gourde
mais je reprendrai pas encore gorgés
[Musique]